I've gotta be honest. We can be shallow. A
Jubilee presents spectrum season five,
episode five blind people.
We invited six blind people to see the range of their beliefs and experiences.
Hey.
I'm Alicia and I'm 31.
I live in Toronto currently and I was diagnosed 10 years ago at Stargardt's
disease. I'm Christine ha I'm in Houston, Texas United States.
I'm best known for winning master chef season three. I am James Raff.
I'm legally blind since birth. And I'm currently in Los Angeles, California.
I'm Lacey Edwards. I'm 24 and I'm based in the United Kingdom.
And I'm best named for being the first ever blind presenter on BBC Ray J one.
And I'm also a year cheaper. Yeah.
I'm Mario bonds. I'm based in Maryland. I am.
Best-known from season two of the glee project and the PBS documentary blind
love.
Hi, I'm Molly Burke. I'm 26 years old in Los Angeles, California.
I have retinitis pigmentosa and I'm a YouTuber motivational speaker and
commercial model.
The first prompt is being blind has enhanced my other
senses. Elisha, somewhat agree.
Christine, somewhat agree. James, somewhat agree.
Lucy disagree. Mario strongly agree.
Molly agree.
Common to say, Oh, are you dead devil?
And I think I just want to smash this misconception.
We don't have like supersonic over senses.
Yes. The misconception that we're somehow superhuman. That drives me nuts.
But I think if I leave out of my house and I've ordered an Uber,
I know my driveway, right. So when I walk out of my house, I'm totally blind,
but immediately my ears say, okay, there's the engine of the car.
I hear the incidental click of the doors unlocking.
And I instantly know where to reach out and grab the door handle.
And of course to the driver, they don't know a blind person just got in there.
I said, somewhat agree because it's more so that I pay attention to things more.
So I don't think necessarily that you get heightened senses.
It's more so that you have to depend on your other four senses when you lose
your vision. I said, I agree because, um,
I lost the majority of my vision at 14. I've been legally blind from birth.
Um, and when I lost my vision,
I immediately struggled to adapt to my other senses.
I really struggled with taste. Uh, I had to eliminate things like garlic, onion,
spicy foods. I also struggled with smell a lot.
I distinctly remember being in a restaurant and they burnt cheese and I had to
leave the restaurant. This was the same year I went blind. So for me,
that was like a truly, uh, heightening of my senses,
but things like my hearing and my touch,
I would say are more based on paying more attention.
Next prompt is I prefer to date fellow blind people.
Alicia disagree, Christine. I disagree.
James disagree, Lucy disagree. Mario disagree,
Molly, somewhat disagree.
I've been told that I'm a pretty beautiful man.
So I need to have somebody keep telling me that I still have myself together.
It's important people to know that just because we are blind,
doesn't mean that we're automatically going to have a blind partner.
We live in the freedom of love coming in whatever condition or situation.
It may be.
Only married to someone who is sighted. And then when I think about it,
I'm like,
life is easier because he can drive me around or tell me if like a certain
ingredient is expired in the pantry. Or tell me if I have food in my teeth.
I said, somewhat disagree. Um,
because I don't prefer to date somebody who is or who isn't,
I'm currently in a relationship with a blind person prior to this.
My partner has only dated sighted women and I've only dated cited men.
I don't care that neither of us can drive because we can still get around.
I don't care that he can't see some of the things that I can't either,
because we can find ways around that. Like using apps,
like be my eyes with my sighted partners in the past,
there was only so much understanding they could have of my lived experience
daily. Whereas every day now I get to come home to a partner that completely
understands my life experience.
Me and Ali have a little bit of a different sort of lift story.
I saw him before I went blind.
I went blind two months into our relationship. So this may sound controversial,
but I feel like he lived my blindness with me.
He felt all of the emotions that I felt as a 17 year old girl,
feeling alone and having this loss and grief.
My sighted partner understands me as
Lucy and understands me as a blind woman,
way deeper than I could ever find in any blind
partner, just because of what we've lived through together.
So we're getting married next year. So, yay.
Congratulations.
I'd love to ask a followup question to people were curious,
are blind people less shallow about romantic partners?
Oh, love that.
I've gotta be honest. We can be shallow a F
One of the first things I'm going to notice is what does your voice sound like?
Hair is a massive thing for me. I love when Ali has his hair cut.
I love his beard.
I noticed the feel of hands the same way a sighted person would notice pretty
eyes.
Well, smell, smell, smell.
Clones, gotta be right. You know how like.
Girls are like, are you into arms or abs? Like, I've always been like,
I'm an arms girl,
because it's the first impression I have of a man when he gives me set a guide.
I'm like, but how's that arm hair situation? How's that arm fitness? Like,
what's that like, you know, bicep, like, yeah, I get my full scope of his,
you know, his makeup.
And there've been times where, you know, the whole side of her was like, Oh,
she doesn't look like she belongs with you,
but I did not care because it's what I found to be attractive both by virtue of
personality and what she felt like to me and everything like that was, was fine.
As shallow as my sighted friends, it's just in different ways.
I do still experience physical and sexual attraction like any sighted person
would. And so, yes, I do have preferences of height of hair, um,
of body type.
Well, I would say the opposite being legally blind actually,
because I've been going through the degeneration of my eye disease for the last
10 years.
Like I was diagnosed when I was 21 and back then I had different preferences for
what I was looking for. And now my preferences are more lifelong. Like,
is this person going to stay by me as my vision degenerate? And because of that,
I don't look so much at what they look like,
because I can't see them as well as I used to.
But also because I need to know that they match me inside.
Unsolicited help makes things hard.
I would say somewhat agree. I'm also somewhat agree.
Strongly agree, somewhat agree, somewhat agree.
Somewhat agree.
This happened the other day at the mall and especially in a post pandemic world,
uh,
I don't necessarily want people getting up in my space and it's hard to sort of
police that as a blind person sometimes, uh, had a security guard,
just literally take hold of me, even know where I was going.
Then I told him and I'm like, I know where I am.
And I just wasn't really comfortable with that scenario.
And then I've had past scenarios where I've actually been literally guided into
traffic. It was kind of a scary scenario and it just all happened so fast.
I really didn't know how to react.
I've been in situations where I've actually been cursed out for refusing help.
I'll get the door for you. Oh no, please. Don't I have it.
And I'll get the door for you. Oh no, I'm fine. I'm fine. I have it.
I'll get the door for you. Oh no, I'm fine.
I was just trying to help your blind. Whoa.
It was almost like as if I robbed them of a Cub scout moment, but it's,
it's more of a respect thing.
I totally agree with you, Maria. I've got Google maps, um,
in my bone conducting headphones and I'm with Olga, my guide dog, you know,
I know where I'm going.
There's a lady who stroked Olga as I was crossing the road.
There's cars coming and you're just like, wow, like where am I? What am I doing?
Then obviously Olga's distracted. Then you're a bit off work.
And I think the motto here should be just ask, don't grab,
just come up to me and say, you know, you look gloss. I'm Sally.
I'm a passer-by. I was you, you, you look like you need help.
Do you need any assistance?
And then that gives the autonomy back to us and to say actually, yeah, I,
I would really love it. Or actually, no, I don't need help right now. Sorry.
I chose somewhat agree for a different reason being as I don't look
blind. When I look at unsolicited help, I think of it as advice,
they tend to give me advice. Like, you know,
maybe you just shouldn't work because this is too much work for you.
It doesn't boost the morale. It doesn't actually help.
And it actually hinders and makes me feel like you don't see me as capable and
inter independent.
I said, somewhat agree. I don't always know that I need help.
So sometimes unsolicited advice or help is actually
really beneficial for me, but overwhelmingly,
I generally will ask for help if I do need it. You know, we have our process.
I might have to sit through, you know,
three cycles of traffic at an intersection.
If I've never crossed out that intersection before, but I'm not lost.
I'm just doing what I need to do to be safe and to accommodate my disability.
And I think all of us like to have as much independence as much freedom as we
can have. And so sometimes interrupting us,
having independence and freedom can be frustrating.
And it does feel like you're underestimating our ability. I will say though,
that I appreciate it.
If my husband tells me my Cane's about to go into dog poo or something.
Fair enough. Fair enough. Oh yeah.
That's my pipe unwanted per the city I live
in is easily accessible for me. Somewhat disagree.
Strongly disagree, somewhat disagree.
Agree, strongly disagree, somewhat disagree.
I spent many years in, um, downtown Los Angeles, which I love,
but whenever people needed me to like leave downtown to like go towards the
beach side or go into the Valley or, you know,
LA is really big and spread out, then it requires me to figure out, okay,
can I combo this between like the Metro and Uber with like the cost of,
and then considering the traffic.
And that's why I'm actually in the process of transitioning my life into a more
accessible city at the moment.
LA is not known for having good public transit.
And it's also just very expensive.
They usually have to purely rely on Uber and Lyft.
I've chosen to live in a very walkable area of LA,
which is also very rare. We have the sidewalk braille,
the nice bumps on the sidewalk.
All of the crossings near me are either vibrating or tweeting.
So for those reasons, yes, my little area is accessible,
but LA as a whole, not,
not quite because of what Molly and James said,
I'm going to flip from somewhat disagree to somewhat agree.
Being that I live in Toronto.
There's a lot of things that I consider blessings here,
but there are things that I need that haven't been thought of.
Because again,
a lot of times when they're trying to be accessible.
Is still an ideology that doesn't encompass all of us. Like,
I love that when the buses come there's audio announcements,
but sometimes the drivers turn them off and I've gone on the wrong bus and gone
the wrong way for half an hour and then had to wander aimlessly.
And because I can't see street signs, I don't know which way I'm going.
Yeah. I'm somewhat agree as well, where I'm from in the UK, in London,
we don't have tweeting crossings. So that is so cool.
We have a little cylinder at the bottom that sort of moves and spins around.
So we know when to cross, but I think London overall,
I'm really lucky because I have the underground and the into ground it's all or
double overall black cabs are amazing.
Me and the copies have a good old chin wag, uh, they're ever so friendly.
So if you're a friend, London definitely get in a black cab, they're so sweet.
I.
I said, strongly disagree. I live in Houston,
which is very much a commuter city.
There are many parts of Houston that have either very terrible sidewalks that
need fixing they're very crooked or they're low hanging branches.
I feel like where there are a lot more pedestrians.
It seems to be more accessible for those who are visually impaired.
Whereas like these wider spreads cities that depend a lot on cars getting to get
around like LA or Houston seems to be less successful.
As a blind individual.
I ended up paying a fortune when I want to be independent.
I ended up paying a fortune in transportation costs. Um, you know,
I look at it like this at any time I want to leave the, leave the house.
It costs me a coin, so to speak.
And not only is it often, you know,
more expensive to be blind because we do have to pay higher rent to live in
these more accessible neighborhoods and just accessible technology and all of
these extra costs in our lives.
But there are also many blind people live in poverty, um,
due to lack of job opportunities. So not only is it more expensive, you know,
we're lower income overall.
Yeah. The, the huge point, you know, 80,
80% of working age blind adults are unemployed.
And as the statistics that have risen steadily since the 1970s.
So that's a really good point.
I am offended when blind is used as one of my descriptive characteristics,
disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree,
agree, strongly disagree.
I strongly disagree with this because I think if I was to be offended,
that means I'm ashamed and I'm not my blindness is, is yes, just a piece of me,
but it is a large piece of me.
And it's a large piece that has informed many of the other pieces of me.
So call me blind.
Cause I am call me short cause I am call me pale because I am,
these are just facts about me. Um, and they don't offend me.
They don't upset me.
They're things that I'm proud of and that I wholeheartedly own.
I do call myself the blind cook.
People do know me as the blind chef so that I do own that because that is a huge
part of who I am.
But I wouldn't say I strongly disagree because I'm of
situations where I'm introduced at something. And then people say like,
she's a chef. Oh, but she's also blind. Isn't that even more amazing.
I don't want to be put on this other pedestal in spite of me.
Yeah. It's interesting because I, I,
I I'm with Christine that where it's a disagree. I do love it.
That in the bio, the bio blindness is the last thing on the list.
I'm, you know, Mario bonds, 32 year old singer songwriter from Maryland.
And then you can add,
he lost his sight to morning glory syndrome at blah-blah-blah.
It's done in a respectable way.
Disagree because I think being diagnosed at 21,
a lot of who I am was still being a sighted person up until 21.
And because of that, I have to honor that.
It's really important that we're all that out there shouting about the blind
message that we're United and we're owning it because for
ages, I didn't want to be blind.
I went blind at 17 and I didn't like the word I lost my
vision and I don't know what to do.
And I'm grieving and there's a loss there and you know,
what are these connotations of this word blind? It's scary. You know,
and I was that girl at school that didn't want to use a cane and didn't want to
own it because there is still a lot of people out there that see the tagline
blind and go, Oh, and you know,
it got a lot easier when I owned my mobility aid and said, right,
I am coming out as blind to the world. And in turn,
I'm coming out as my self I'm liberated, I'm free.
And this is me.
And it just felt like you were breathing a sigh of relief being blind.
It's affected my mental health. Strongly agree, strongly agree.
Somewhat disagree, strongly agree, strongly agree.
Strongly agree.
So having been born legally blind, I never knew anything different.
It wasn't until the kids become more aware and stuff and poke out differences
and, and really nag on those that that's when I really had that whole
journey of, uh, my mental health and,
and being diagnosed with mental illnesses and stuff. But that really,
I don't blame my blindness. I blame the individuals that may have, uh,
really resulted in my mental health deteriorating.
And it wasn't actually until, uh, so I got like a surgery.
It was experimental. I did regain vision, um, for the first time.
And it was considered just visually impaired on the Mark.
And that only lasted for about two years and then overnight,
it all just deteriorated, went back to how it was. And, um,
I didn't find happiness until after I went blind again. Um,
I think it was just because this is how I'm supposed to experience life because
I feel like there's a greater purpose for it, uh, in my life.
And I got to do something with that.
James, I appreciate what you said.
I thought that was quite powerful because I hadn't thought of it like that
before being a person who has been in several situations where I was taken
advantage of, um, whether it was by a family member, whether it was,
you know, a teacher molesting me as a teenager or even just more recently,
whether it's kids being kids and kids trying to, you know,
kind of get over on their blind parent. Um, of course I'm on it now,
but all of those things, you know, kind of bleed into,
into one principal theme that we are blind. Um,
and sometimes you're,
you're going to go to those emotional corners where I resent being blind because
of, you know, what people might do to, you know,
weaponized my circumstance. Um, so, you know, James,
you really said something that stuck with me there.
Mario. I appreciate how you phrased all that and shared all that.
It's hard, isn't it? It's one of those things where you look back and you think,
wow, why me? I guess that's what I did at the start.
I was with my tub of Ben and Jerry's little bed.
Yeah. Yeah. And I was that girl. I was the only girl in my family,
in my friendship group. Everyone cited me,
wishing she had a sight back and you know,
my organ died in front of my eyes. It's like,
of course I'm gonna feel low. You know? I mean, it is a.
The grieving process. It's definitely not just vision loss.
It's a loss of losing a sense of self as well.
It's a loss of having hopes and desires for a future that might not be
what it is. It might be better.
It won't be what you envisioned it to be originally. Right?
Blind people are three times more likely to deal with depression and anxiety.
So if you are blind and you struggle with mental illness, um,
you don't have to feel alone.
We statistically are more susceptible to struggling with it.
And to me it makes sense. Ultimately,
we're living in a world that isn't designed or created for us and we're making
our way and we're doing it and we're killing it,
but it does make life in certain, certain circumstances, more difficult.
I have experienced discrimination.
And would agree, strongly agree, strongly agree, strongly agree,
strongly agree, strongly agree.
I was the only one that said somewhat [inaudible].
I wonder if the difference is, is given we all use mobility AIDS. Um.
No, actually there's this intersectionality between living my entire life as a
black woman and being,
as I've only been diagnosed with this disease and lived with it for the last 10
years,
I can see a clear difference between the discrimination of being black versus
the discrimination of being blind.
When I tell people that I've gone through something or faced discrimination as a
black female,
sometimes I'm met with doubt or kind of like pushing it to the
side or it's in your head, or it's not that bad.
Whereas I feel like people meet me halfway when it comes to my vision, loss,
people find it admirable and kind of attached to it, identity as inspirational.
It's a different energy. It's a different temperature,
which is why I said somewhat not strongly.
As a blind black man.
I can say that I've experienced discrimination on both fronts. Uh,
unfortunately, you know, the crux of me is really the arts.
I did try out for American idol. There's several rounds of auditions.
You have to go through to get on these reality shows.
And this is like the first level of it.
They're at my guitar and I sing my heart out. And then the producer,
he stopped me and said, dude,
normally we really don't let blind people through. And even if we do,
we don't usually let them go so far goes there.
They can be so difficult to deal with during production. The man you're so dope.
I got to say yes,
That type of stuff really can leave you feeling unaccomplished because obviously
you want to be seen for your ability.
You want to be seen for the content of your character,
but unfortunately that doesn't always happen.
And that can do a bigger plug to earlier conversation we had
that can sometimes be a catalyst for a plunge into momentary
depression as well.
I do feel like,
like the bulk of the discrimination that I face is due to my guide dog.
And it's only getting increasingly worse as the,
the misuse of service dogs and the use of fake service dogs
increases. I've been a guide dog user for 13 years now.
And over the last five year over year, it gets worse and worse and worse.
And I face more and more and more discrimination.
I strongly agree when I'm entering a say,
people see my guide dog and not the person who needs a
ride. I've had someone spits out me, um,
and tell and swear at me. Um, and you know,
even though now I found great taxi drivers in central London,
um, it still does scare me.
Job related stuff. Uh, I've been in those interviews. Um,
everything seems to go well, they're giving me an estimation of like,
when I'm going to hear back, Oh, it's gonna be next Tuesday. Yeah. We even want,
you know, maybe even had this department.
And then when you start mentioning accommodations in the conversation sort of
shifts, and then next thing I know I get an automated, uh, you know, uh,
decline like three email, 30 days later,
instead of hearing back on that Tuesday.
Oftentimes people come approach and, you know, want to ask to take a photo.
They'll always ask my husband, like,
is it okay if I take a photo with Christine? There's just things like that.
That I think a lot of people don't think about.
I feel like when someone asks somebody else,
if they are allowed to take a photo with me that I'm a lesser person, um, that,
you know, I cannot make my own independent decision.
I know it's a sighted world,
but I always find that amazing that because of the preconceived notion and what
they think blind people should look like, or shouldn't look like that,
I I'll be it. I think it's ridiculous that I even get things like, you know,
there, there's no way this guy is blind. He's muscular. And it's like, what,
what do you mean?
Yeah, blindness is quite rare.
I think the main place that people get their opinion on what blindness must be
like is through entertainment because I choose to put myself out there online
and I don't quote,
look blind or look the way people think I'm supposed to. As a disabled woman,
I get a lot of she's faking it. You know, this whole Reddit threads,
there's whole blogs devoted to trying to debunk my blindness.
And that's why representation is so important.
And that's why videos like this one is so important to watch to share,
um, because we need the education to spread. So that, that ignorance is, um,
is combated with education.
If I could regain my sight with a cure,
I would want to strongly agree, somewhat agree,
strongly disagree, disagree, strongly agree. Disagree.
If I was to get my sight back,
I would love to see the faces of the children that I've adopted.
That would be amazing.
I said, disagree.
I might answer probably a good four years ago would have been the complete
opposite. I'm going to have my wedding next year.
And there's so much of me that wants to see Ali's face when I'm walking down the
aisle or my mom's face or my sister's face, or my dad's face again,
because they have now faded from my memory that does hurt me
inside quite deeply. And just thinking of the milestones really in life.
Um, having kids is only in the future,
but I think the reason that my answer is disagree is because I have finally
come to accept who I am and the fact that I really do deeply believe
now that life without sight is truly beautiful.
When I embraced that, that's when I don't want my sight back.
I don't need it to feel fulfilled. And to feel that you say,
I said disagree like Lucy, for many of the same reasons. Um,
at the beginning of my vision loss, I dealt with a lot of anger,
resentment. I threw myself pity parties asked why me,
all I wanted was my sight back. In fact,
I was literally the youth ambassador for a charity whose sole purpose was to
fundraise, to find a cure for my disease.
And along my self acceptance and self love journey,
I realized how toxic that mindset was for me.
And that's where the social model versus medical model comes in.
The medical model is the idea that the answer to disability is curing
it, um, which puts really the onus on the disabled person.
We are the burden on society and we need to change be fixed,
be healed in order to be whole or good enough or fit into society.
Whereas the social model of disability says actually the disabled person is
perfectly fine and they aren't the problem at all.
The real problem is societies in accessibility with our infrastructure in terms
of, you know, the design of our buildings and our physical space around us,
but also our technology, um,
and just everything we use and interact with on a daily basis.
So for all of those reasons, I don't want to cure. So have.
Gone through a bit of a process of trying to cure my site,
uh, back when I was about 11 years old,
feeling pressured to do so in order to fit in.
And it reverting back within two years,
I was never happy during those two years because I wasn't doing it for me.
It really didn't feel like I was myself until I was able to really embrace my
blindness. One in seven people in the world have some form of disability.
And that may only increase as time goes on. I know for me,
and the purpose that I'm here on this earth to do it's to leave this world a
more accessible and accepting place than I found it.
I answered somewhat agree. Ideally,
I think I would want my vision back for like maybe a couple days just so I can
watch some foreign films, see what, you know,
maybe my friends and family look like now,
but then I feel like I don't necessarily want my
full vision back forever because I think I'm kind of at the halfway point in my
life where I've lived half of my life with vision and half of it without.
So it would be so different in difficult.
And I think losing my vision,
put me in a position where I was forced to think
outside of the box and create opportunities for myself and be more
courageous,
but it would be kind of cool just to see what cars look like nowadays,
I've come more into myself and kind of like what Christine said.
There's a lot about all of our characters that couldn't have been wouldn't have
been, had it not been the challenges of losing her vision.
I feel like I could take the last 10 years and the character development and
take that forward, whether I'm visually impaired.
Yeah. I don't think I would be the person I am today.
If I hadn't lost my vision. But past that, you know,
I really work hard to be the coolest flying dad ever.
My kids don't miss the beat.
I'm able to chase in play with my seven and 10 year old. Um,
I boxed with my team, my, my teenagers, they think I'm Superman. Cause they,
they see me work out all the time and we play and we do this and we do that.
I'm content just being I'm super blind, Mario.
Any of you. But sometimes when I think about who I would be, if I was cited,
like it's scares me. I'm like, I don't know who that person would be.
And I'm so happy with this person then I'm like, I don't want to see you.
She would be this person's good. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I need to think about that.
I wholeheartedly respect everyone's journey and everyone's perspective. Yeah.
Yeah. Definitely. Blindness is a spectrum home rules.
No, this was great. You guys, this is an amazing bunch.
I'm so honored to meet everybody and, and just.
Yeah. Beautiful experience. I loved hearing you guys.
All of you. It's so nice meeting all of you. I hope we can all stay in touch.
Yeah, it sounds good. It was nice talking to everybody.
I'm going to go to bed now guys. Take care. Everyone, stay safe.